es war es war ein einfacher klick das
kann passieren aber in der konsequenz
ist einfach so eine peinliche sachen
service s kids und herzlich willkommen
zu einer neuen folge
minecraft dies war habe ich den
richtigen button gedrückt alter leute
ich muss ich muss ich muss sagen ich
würde wirklich wird sagen wir spielen
erst mal hier ein bisschen dann erzähle
euch das aber ohne witz dass ich habe
einfach gerade eben wahrscheinlich den
krassesten fällen meines lebens begangen
so ungefähr auf youtube und das war dass
das war garantiert einer der krassesten
fails meines lebens ich werde euch
gleich wer erzählt aber als aller erstes
mal
ihr werdet ihr werde ich werde euch
wahrscheinlich weiterhin ablachen also
die leute davon gehört haben haben sich
ordentlich ein gegönnt
und während wir auch dabei und ihr könnt
euch denken wieder gelacht hat übrigens
wäre es auch jetzt gerade dabei in der
beschreibung natürlich verlinkt ich fand
es war mein gott ich war nicht flüssig
leute die sache war die ich mache ja ich
nehme auf mich nehme auf mit
openbroadcast und openbroadcast ist so
programmiert worden dass alle buttons
für alle funktionen von broadcaster sehr
nahe beieinander liegen
das heißt man kann sich da durchaus auch
mal blicken
ja und dann ist es jetzt so dass man mit
openbroadcast nicht nur aufnehmen kann
sondern auch stream
jetzt können sich manche von euch weiß
schon denken was passiert ist
ich habe einfach gerade eben wollte ich
mit wären ohne dzombic aufnehmen denkt
man so alles chillig ok am ende hat er
wieder eine pipi gemacht der nutzen so
aber hat gewonnen aber es hat alles hat
alles gepasst ich denke so schwierig
hier aufnahme beenden
alles klar schauen sie auf den button
nichts mit aufnahme steht aufnahme
starten und oben drüber steht streaming
stoppen und dann war die sache einfach
die dass ich einfach nicht so dass ich
mich verliebt habe und eine
viertelstunde lang gestreamt habe
anstatt aufzunehmen
und das allerbeste ist ich habe mich
irgendwie gestreamt sondern ich habe
einfach gemietet gestimmt weil ich
meinen ton separat aufnehmen möchte ich
mein mikro in obs das heißt ich habe
jetzt einfach eine viertel stunde
gemietet gestreamt und das einfach
gemerkt danach das wahlalter das war
geil ich denke so etwas kann ich seine
gehe auf twitter immerhin 120 zuschauern
es geht alles es geht alles er läutet
das war das war mir gerade so peinlich
für alle die nicht eingeschaltet haben
sich denken was macht der basta warum
ist er gemietet
ich habe dich nicht geschaut weil ich
nicht angedacht haben könnte
ohne witz
es ist schon krass es war es war ein
einfacher klick
das kann passieren aber in der
konsequenz einfach so eine peinliche
sache oh mein gott
also ich glaube dieser fluss immer noch
angepisst weil wir den zerstörten sie
nicht herr wasser wasser wasser jetzt
geschafft oder ja ich sag ja jump league
bin ich der escalade und 90 als playdom
dick viele falter mein vorteil 50 wtr
wie macht man das ist das ist kaka nicht
herunter mein alter immer wenn ich
darüber nachdenke dass das wären roth
hat nach vorn logo dann passiert schon
bedingt an kati ab stehen im fokus die
augen hielt der feile an die fraser geil
stieg deutlich gefallen
eine ohne bezahlt weil es mit dem jungen
den jungen los alter reisefreiheit extra
etf an
nicht die male ich mir ein bisschen zu
bringen
lauf lauf lauf erst mal um dein leben
nach am besten noch an so dass apps
gehen und nicht nur das mache ich jetzt
allen vortag war die um 8 uhr kommt noch
hinzu
singing ja genau also also alle die
sehen wollen wie das dann aussieht wenn
ich wirklich mal stream ein alter der
klassiker so jetzt von einer klausel
alter 38 vorne
spontan ja nein da kommt und wer ihm
place alter anstatt dass du auf den
anderen ist denke ich auch
naja danach auf einer nacht ja
übertreibt was war das für eine nacht
nach unten hatten nach unten fünf blöcke
kann man mal machen
was man ins leben
zwar verletzte warum werde ich all das
gibt's nicht alter wtf geben die leute
die hier ist das kranke ohne witz
es passt heute abend alles zusammen so
mein eigener fehler
diese ganzen lex ihr alter thomalla ich
habe wer ihm rangiert
aber dann kommt ein anderer hat mich
wirklich du bist auch tot
die runde war auch bolt hat kurz dadurch
dass wir so gas gegeben hat wtf aber
leute ich glaube wenn ich wenn ich die
geschichte nochmal erzähle mit dem feld
da kann ich das einfach nicht nochmal so
rüberbringen
deswegen würde ich sagen lasst uns mal
dabei es gibt heute abend macht wieder
in stream übrigens schon gerne ein wenn
ihr wollt tv stick entsorgt lassen sich
gefallen hat wir sind bei der nächsten
folge wieder wäre mist und in der
beschreibung verlinkt bis dann